Oh
hello welcome back to GameSpot's
continuing coverage of e3 2015 and i'm
joined by ian from X dev and Michael
from house mark all the way finland
what's up you came pretty far right
langland somewhere England I'm from
Leeds yeah leeds pretty fun AIDS is
pretty far you gotta get you gotta find
an airport they leaves England first
then you gotta get your ass over here
build 10 exactly exactly hey you guys
hear what alienation have you guys of
course resogun are very successful game
k man dead nation super stardust so
three games right now with the help our
friends on the ps4 previous generations
also so yeah alien issues will get good
yeah it's he'll tell us about it how
long you been working on it first of all
um well it's always like from ideas
stage to the first prototype to text us
a long time I forget but it's been on it
works for a while we first announced it
gamescom 2013 oh really yeah yeah two
years ago a little bit before then and
take the signs we've got old gamescom i
like when gamescom gets a share with
some announcements it's the way it's
you're basically representing the best
of European development and I have to
say the trailer gamescom one of what's
one of the kind of NC 18 there was a
guy's face exploding I don't know how it
looks good it's good [ __ ] it was happen
now where it works excellent I feel like
your studio hash mark was really sort of
flew into the public consciousness with
razor gone it was a game that did very
successful in PlayStation 4 also came in
on PS Vita and on ps3 but for folks who
don't know about alienation what exactly
is it so alienation is this very
action-packed top-down shooter so it's
it's got some RPG elements you can get
loot so shooting and looting is the
basis of the game but then you kind of
focus on the Arkady a tactical shooting
with a up to a team of four so you can
really get together with your friends
communicate take down bacon small
enemies different objectives and they
get some nice loot to upgrade as a
reward and so is it one sort of story
that continues through each level or I
think individual campaign there is a
kind of overarching a story about aliens
invading Earth conspiracies from the
history so for example one of the levels
is in prypiat which is the charitable
yeah
and that was kind of a cover-up of
actually aliens being there I won't go
into too much details but now there's
this whole thing it's like else is there
culprit ruling we don't talk about it
over yet but it's a big thing like about
aliens though they could be here right
now like III could be an alien
conspiracy you know what that would
explain quite a lot exactly yeah so
that's we're living in an alien nation
and we just don't know it yet that's
basically so in terms of the gameplay
that you said it sits for a four player
co-op up to four players co-op it's
dropping drop out so basically if I
start playing I do some missions get
some loot Ian can just jump in and be
like hey Michael let's go take on this
harder difficulty to get some more lu
two different kinds of rare stuff so
there's always this different levels of
difficulty you ever have a sort of AI co
op people with it you or does the
difficulty just scale when you look
scaled yes holds my six guys and there's
a lot of things that we're still working
on so yeah I'm sure to subside the game
especially with a variety of different
enemy types and many people can be
playing different weapons there's lots
of variables about trying to like insane
how many we got teleporting aliens we
got a huge alien shield alias ninja
aliens and everything can have an elite
variant as well like because at the RPG
elements me that we can spawn in a
random alien but easily and it'll mess
you up for a quick so and look at those
graphics too that's me that's me play
now that's you better playing with her
look how good that is so when one of the
greatest things about this as well is
that obviously you guys are are no
strangers to creating these types of
games yeah but with new consoles you're
able to do like 10 80 60 as well I was
watching some gameplay of this on
youtube last week and it really looks
absolutely you probably may probably
isn't in 1080 60 on our live stream but
looks really pretty sweet Elena we're
working out the kinks it's working on
proprietary engines doing pretty well
and for us it's about optimal
performance how's Marcus always been
like a tech center company yeah so we'll
try to get as many explosions on the
screen while still having a really good
experience keeping it up there so we'll
be announcing specs later on go
and I think it's a really important
pillar for you guys I think certainly we
raised all good it's what we're like how
smart funny I get emotional whenever we
start talking about tech a little bit
but for example there's a lot of physics
in there too most of its to make it look
impressive even here the delight on the
ice you can see shine like that so it's
all physical physical based rendering
there's a lot going on there really cool
lights and shadows and everything and
other than that it's just a pure kind of
adrenaline arcade shooter so it's a
simple thing in the kind of a Faberge
egg cool the mice Faberge egg reference
to think that we blow up in super 90
million speak with dynamo so the the the
loot obviously that the everyone loves
the lutron like trying to like get as
much stuff as possible is the loot are
there different characters and you're
sort of leveling up the loot freedom you
know what we thought so I mean as of
what we're showing today we've got free
bait free main character classes that's
tank ela and sort of a DPS he's our
wrong each one of those have got every
characters got an individual sort of
talent tree so you can spec the
character as you want but not only that
every weapon that drops is random and
has its own talent tree as well they
level up with you you can choose the
right loadout so your glasses have like
defense buffs that will help the whole
team one guy has those shields or you
can see I see that's the tank
super-powered right on right there and
then the other one will heal the other
one with making a visible so on and so
on yeah so you can really cooperate with
the different classes but like Ian said
each weapon has an upgrade tree for its
own so that's just like multiplies
everything and yeah yes it's how many
types of weapons are there what are we
talking about seven I've never counted
they send all these potentially more
than that you have free slots and I
can't list them all if there's main
slots and then you can kind of and then
you have the classic so you have let
common uncommon yeah it can legendary
weapons and then this mutate is
something to celebrate we we haven't
really discussed to III because it's the
first time we've really showing it but
we'll be coming back to that that's a
whole other HD it's the reason to keep
played and we want it to be a long tail
campaign as other people
keep coming back that's all new stuff
for how smart like if you look at that
nation there is some you can buy weapons
you can upgrade stuff and it's very
linear this is the first time we're kind
of doing this a more of a shooting lewd
kind of thing I am and even if or four
players it's a our first 4 player game
so says is it what happens if there's a
sweet drop of a weapon is it first
person personally we don't want people
falling out I mean there's some little
aspects that we want some players maybe
to fight each other at some point that's
gonna be able secret we'll talk about
later cool but other than that we want
everybody to keep the peace yeah
presumably then it'd be difficult to do
that on one machine is there is any
split screen stuff going on or is this
all I'm not as enough right now we're
focusing on online and i think that
there's so many ps4 is out there and you
really get that personal experience it's
a lot about communicating with your team
and to be honest a local thing would be
cool but maybe would hinder that sorry
Don and yeah so focusing on this for now
cool and you are updating resogun as
well after all the sky yes just go
wipeout ships man wipeout really now the
soundtrack faiz ours and yeah I'm the
Ori comms and their scent of London in
there somewhere who is it there's this
answer I came out so this the soundtrack
sir it's all good people really excited
about likes and that's it was that was
included in season pass content so
that's like so basically we have the
cheapest season pass off all time ever
with the most content and we did it it's
always six pounds or something to
expansion with the sound would have
seven dollars yeah yeah and you get
everything excellent Anna came in as
well on non Vitas are you guys gonna do
the same with this it's gonna be ps4
only you got well see you guys this is
all from a developer perspective pauper
again I mean we are we are we are the
tech guys yeah and we want to get like
ps4 is such an awesome platform to make
the most explosions and just wreak havoc
you know so for us the beta would lead a
lot of focus so we're not yeah as a team
we're not focusing on anything like that
we're focusing on bringing the best
performance for the ps4 that's similar
to why you do a res ago and I guess you
should have got it at the door and then
the bursar gun it's funny how it looks
sort of a you know Arkady and simple but
underneath the like we just took all the
power and made everything explode very
close to haha yeah you gotta focus on
Brad first and then have a kiss house
mark how many people do you have what do
we have now about 50 people 50 yeah and
you know we're always kind of just
working on games and multiple projects
kind of happening on it a little bit a
little bit we like to be on der in the
Arkady things yeah and we're really
hardcore gamers of heart and we don't
really know how to tell stories so we
hire somebody these guys help out as
long we like to help I think we've been
together now so long it's you know it's
we love these guys actually seven years
seven years but before that even we MGR
did the collaboration so start us series
when the Sun it's like our Uncle Tony
yeah yeah yeahs next day looks like it's
been working here for you guys it's a
big part of how smart yeah its purport
of the brand awesome so you're like you
guys said it will be coming up on two
years since you first had answered and
when will we actually be able to pay any
nation well it's a corporate again I
good again so when I'll take this from
the corporate you we're not talking
release dates right now great because
because I think like we were discussing
this before we came on how smart games
we like to put out when they're ready
yeah we will once we know where they
were a pre alpha stage right now but
we're not very gentle bit until we're
like so yeah that's a good spin that's a
good bet I can really feel like we you
know what I hate I hate like this oh
there's a day one patch you know
everything yeah yeah but if I play
something I want the best experience
from day one and I want to be running
with that I mean I have I by early
access games i'm cool with that but then
again if i'm gonna release something
i'll make sure maybe i'm sure that is
ready so you're not having i like that
no more patches freaky weddings are so
it's so it's soon to you soon basically
yeah so
yeah excellent and one last question
actually before you guys go because
you're so experienced obviously then
making games for the playstation
platform as a whole and august leave
what x stabbed you're used to working
with a lot of developers who are making
games to your platforms yeah and are we
kind of at the tail end of playstation 3
being an option furred for developers
because that like it seems like the like
the crafting games for ps4 is quite
different infrastructure wise than ps3
so are we in a place there where like
ps3 is kind of we're gonna see the last
games appearing on there well for
example resogun was a launch title yeah
we got into that really well and it it's
not like a step backwards to going back
but I think that we're always focusing
on such a specific architecture but it
with the size of you know 50 even as a
team it would be hard to do that all
right but if we outsource or if we have
friends come in and help us that may be
but for us only pay station for for now
yeah I'm what about yourself to Harry
how do you feel about is 3 is a
continuing but I think well it's still
an appetite for it you know we'll still
wearing pointers to bring the best games
that we can to the PlayStation system so
while there's an appetite for it
absolutely we'll keep doing it that I've
seen no memo so yeah yeah excellence
Michael nyan thank you so much for
coming on gamespot sage and talking to a
spare you nation another weird hearing
more about it soon maybe gamescom you
could maybe say something then maybe let
your aleem Elliot well alright i'll see
you there i'm actually going over i
can't wait should be fun physically
family you know and we'll be back on the
game spot stages so tumor alienation in
the comments below and I stay tuned to
gamespot com for more from here at e3
2015